my personal opinion about it is that
network of people who communicate online
are not necessarily a community and one
of the things that signals the formation
of community is that they begin to
enforce norms so there's a lot of bad
stuff going on online now there was a
lot of bad stuff going online all the
time now there's just a lot more people
online and when I started writing the
book the thought that occurred to me
that I thought about a lot was what's
the most important thing about this
communication medium if as we believe a
lot of people are gonna be using it and
that brought me to the idea of the
public sphere that political
philosophers had been talking about that
I didn't have not known about until I
asked and it's the idea that democracy
is not just about voting for your
leaders it's not having a population who
are free enough to communicate and
educated enough to have conversations
that form public opinion and that public
opinion would influence policy and
there's a lot of bugs in that
particularly these days and I'd have to
say that my the critical uncertainty was
will the public sphere be improved by
people communicating online will
democracy be improved will individuals
have more freedom and I have to say that
I don't feel very optimistic or hopeful
about that now but the difference
between optimism and and and hopefulness
is that hope is a choice and so I think
one of the things that everybody in this
this room can do is to think about how
might we improve the the public sphere I
don't know that you can do it in a
top-down way and I do think that
education has a great deal to do with it
and our schools our educational
institutions certainly aren't meeting
that challenge
you